a swarm of bloodthirsty entities waits
outside the protective boundary that
surrounds the solar system they surge
through the vacuum of space looking for
vulnerabilities in the force field that
protects us from their destructive
powers the creatures ran themselves
against the barrier again and again
trying to break through upon impact the
force field shimmers a golden color and
displays a series of thumaturgical
symbols
but it holds suddenly something flies
through the protective shield from
inside the solar system it leaves a hole
two creatures enter our solar system
before the shield closes
this may be the end for humanity the
sixth overseer sits at a computer
terminal massaging the bridge of his
nose he is just logged into the
foundation database to gather
information on an anomaly whose
intentions are still unknown the o5
council wants him to vote on an extreme
measure but he requires more information
first there is something coming he can
feel it and he thinks it has something
to do with
scp-1548 05-6 straightens his back and
sits up in his chair he logs back into
the foundation database and brings up
the entry for scp-1548
he knows that this scp has been
connected to some odd occurrences
recently but what are its true
intentions is scp-1548 trying to help
save the universe
or is it a malicious entity hell bent on
destroying it
05-6 must find out he scrolls through
the first few entries
scp-1548 itself is a series of solar
phenomena that occur at the south pole
of the sun
during these events the sun's plasma
morphs into different thaumaturgical
symbols each symbol is tens of thousands
of miles across the symbols themselves
have not all been classified by the
foundation yet but there are three that
have been observed multiple times the
first is an unnamed symbol that when
inscribed on a telescopic device by a
person with tharmaturgical abilities can
identify psionic entities with malicious
intents the second symbol is known as
the calfastian isle which when displayed
on a material strengthens it immensely
and gives it the ability to absorb
kinetic and electromagnetic energy the
final symbol is the twelve holy owls of
cyrinthium when this symbol is affixed
to an object any entity that is killed
by it will immediately annihilate and
take everything in its radius with it
o5-6 shots a note on the pad of papers
sitting on his desk he has seen some of
these symbols before they are connected
to the ortufin mythology the
practitioners of this religion are known
as the church of the second heitoth and
are a mix of human and alien entities
whose main purpose is to aid the
guardian deity of the universe rakmoo
leosen in combating any threat that may
try to wipe out this existence there
must be a connection between the church
of the second high toth and scp-1548
05-6 thinks he scrolls back through the
scp-1548
file to the entry logged on may 17 1983
the first time an event connected to
scp-1548 was recorded a probe picked up
the manifestation of thaumaturgic
symbols on the south pole of the sun it
was odd but nothing other than the
manifestation of the symbols seemed to
occur this event was recorded as
extranormal event 9008 and logged into
the scp database the event was all but
forgotten until december 23 2016 when
the activity of scp-1548
really began to pick up on that day
scp-1548 began manifesting protection
symbols in rapid succession over the
next few months a dense cloud of ionized
gas formed around the solar system this
ionized wall of radiation surrounded the
heliopause the boundary where the sun's
radiation gives way to the vacuum of
space over time this cloud became
thicker until no light from outside of
the solar system could enter foundation
censorship protocols were quickly used
to disseminate false data suggesting
that the solar system was passing
through a dense cloud of cosmic dust and
that was what was altering the night sky
and causing the stars to disappear but
as o5-6 continues to scan the files he
knows what the true cause of this
phenomenon is it must be
scp-1548 but why is the anomaly trying
to protect us from something outside of
our solar system or is it trying to trap
humanity within with no means of escape
05-6 stands up and stretches ah that's
enough for today he says out loud to the
empty room he walks towards the door and
reaches for the handle all of a sudden
sirens start going off and red lights
begin to flash 05-6 spins around and
runs back to the computer terminal an
emergency alert begins coming through
the falcon light 5 rocket that launched
earlier in the day to bring supplies to
the international space station has
spontaneously lost 50 percent of its
mass mid-flight 05-6 frantically begins
typing he brings up videos from
surveillance satellites the overseer
watches in horror as pieces of debris
and bodies of the crew flow through the
silence of space the rocket looks like
it has been cut directly down the middle
and half of the structure has vanished
from existence what is happening
suddenly another alert comes in all
communication has been lost with the
international space station without
warning the space station begins
broadcasting a series of cognito hazards
05-6 quickly changes the channel to stop
the signal from transmitting through his
computer reports start coming in from
around the world that anyone who
continued listening to the cognitohazard
signals began entering trances then
their brain completely evaporated from
their skulls there is a surge of
thermoturgic particles in orbit around
the earth o5-6 traces the particles back
to their source they came from scp-1548
the signal from the iss stops abruptly
the entire space station changes course
it is on a trajectory to re-enter the
earth's atmosphere the friction and heat
will rip the space station apart 05-6
can't believe what is happening it seems
as if scp-1548 helped humanity in a way
by stopping the signals from the iss but
how can he be sure that scp-1548 wasn't
responsible for the cognito hazards in
the first place he needs more
information 05-6 searches for answers as
more anomalies connected to scp-1548
start occurring around the world during
a political demonstration in berlin a
thamaturgic way opens up that leads to a
pocket dimension soon after the
appearance of the portal koru arch
priest farah attainus the leader of the
church of the second haith makes an
announcement he claims that the way
leads to a shelter which will protect
people from the coming doom of the
universe the people in the area along
with the members of the church of the
second high toth make their way into the
portal two undercover foundation agents
follow the group after everyone is
entered the way immediately closes and
there is no further contact what does
the church of the second high top know
that we don't 05-6 wonders he continues
monitoring the situation and looking for
answers suddenly a message comes through
all foundation channels it is coming
from the sun it is not scp-1548
instead it is scp-179
the humanoid permanently in space near
the sun 179 sends out one clear word in
its signal defend who is scp-179 talking
to 05-6 thinks what needs to be defended
is it humanity our solar system the
universe another alarm begins to go off
what now 05-6 screams he brings up the
alert the screen flashes to the moon
05-6 focuses in on where the alert is
coming from it is a foundation base
called area 32 what remains left of the
base is reporting that
scp-2821 suddenly expanded in size
formed a wormhole that led to another
region of the universe and then vanished
through it taking 38 foundation members
and 10 anomalies with it sirens continue
to go off distress signals are being
picked up on every channel it seems as
if the world is coming to an end and
everything that is happening is somehow
connected to scp-1548
a static field transmission begins
coming in from scp-3417
the words are urgent all are toughens
here all our tothens must listen now the
stars are lost static breaks up the
transmission for a few moments before it
resumes ago the first invasion occurred
the gods were unprepared never
comprehending the fragility of the
universe after its creation the worlds
must fight the transmission cuts off
everything goes silent a pulsating scp
icon appears on the screen of 05-6's
computer it is the part of the puzzle he
has been waiting for in 1999 the o5
council unanimously voted to launch a
mission called serif one to explore
beyond the heliosphere and the mission's
true purpose was to explore the
plausibility of extraterrestrial scp
objects in space the message that 05-6
just received is from serif one it is
relaying information back to earth the
video shows the barrier of ionized
radiation that
scp-1548 had created glowing orange at
the border of the heliopause
the radioactive wall seems to be made up
of complex geometric patterns
around 6 000 miles across seraph 1
accelerates towards the barrier it
smashes through the protective shell the
probe has entered interstellar space
05-6 knows that everything he is seeing
is on a delay as the information being
sent back by serif one needs to travel
vast distances and it takes significant
time for signals to reach earth after
passing through the ionized barrier the
connection to serif one is lost over the
next few days 05-6 tries to link the
anomalies happening in the solar system
to scp-1548
the foundation still hasn't concluded
that 1548 is harmful or trying to
protect the solar system in some way
then a message comes in from serif one
it has briefly regained communication
with the foundation most of the probe's
instruments have been destroyed but its
rear-facing camera is still broadcasting
05-6 pulls up the feed he stares at the
screen in horror as the images unfold
before him the camera captures swarms of
unknown entities surrounding the
heliopause the bodies of the entities
are asymmetrical with countless
appendages and unknown structures
jutting out from their cores they seem
to range in size from 10 kilometers to
10 000 kilometers across although some
seem so large that their size can only
be hypothesized the swarms crash into
the protective barrier that
scp-1548 has created around the solar
system each time part of the swarm rams
the barrier thousands of thalmaturgic
symbols and solar flares appear at the
point of impact two entities that are
later classified as 1548 omega 1 and
1548 omega 2 are captured entering the
solar system by serif one's camera
video from serif one shows that as the
probe exited through the protective
barrier it created a hole that remained
open for a few moments during the time
that the shield of ionized radiation was
vulnerable
1548-omega-1 and 1548-omega-2
entered through it they are now inside
the solar system
scp-1548 launches countermeasures in the
form of glowing red sigils that create
shock waves to slow down omega-1 and
omega-2 omega-1 is shaped like an eel
with five contorted arms radiating from
its body and a mouth made of impossible
geometric shapes omega-2 has a
tetrahedral structure that leaves a
trail of black rocks in its wake as the
two entities move towards the sun
1548 becomes more active it closes the
hole in the barrier before any other
creatures of the swarm can enter and
then launches hundreds of concentrated
blasts of thalmic energy at omega-2 the
flares vaporize the entity in seconds
the last thing the video feed of serif
dash 1 captures before it cuts out is
omega-1 disappearing from view as it
creeps towards the center of the solar
system it has escaped the protective
measures of scp-1548
after the o5 council reviews the footage
they decide to deploy the scps cortana
to intercept omega-1 the orbital vessel
is fully equipped with experimental
anomalous weapons and propulsion systems
the council is sure that the cortana
will be able to destroy omega-1 data
coming in from other satellites indicate
that omega-1 has destroyed pluto and
other kuiper belt objects it is slowly
making its way to the center of the
solar system annihilating everything in
its path the kurtana intercepts omega
dash 1 near jupiter and engages the
creature after 10 minutes of battling
communication with the ship is lost
probes in the area capture footage of
the cortana and omega-1 in mid-battle
when they are suddenly surrounded by a
black substance and both vanish from
sight 05-6 and the other council members
watch in anticipation unsure of what has
just happened then the black substance
dissipates the scps cortana sits
motionless in space the entity is
nowhere to be seen a cheer erupts from
the overseers and foundation members in
the room it seems the entity has been
defeated then without warning the
cortana accelerates rapidly it is on a
collision course with mars as the ship
hurtles past one of the probes in the
asteroid belt the foundation members see
an organic mass resembling that of
omega-1 attached to the hull of the ship
the overseer council watches in horror
as the scps cortana smashes into the red
planet leaving a crater 250 miles wide
the energy released from the impact
instantly ionizes the thin atmosphere of
mars causing the surface to turn into
molten rock from the epicenter of the
impact crater a black organic mass
begins to crawl across the planet the
overseers are frozen in fear but scp-15
immediately deals with the entity that
is devouring the surface of mars from
the sun comes the largest
scp-1548 instance ever recorded a solar
flare is jettisoned towards mars the
impact causes a fusion reaction so
intense that for a moment mars shines as
brightly as the sun the planet explodes
its debris is cast across the solar
system over time it will create a second
asteroid belt in the orbit that mars
once inhabited the overseer council is
now convinced that the threat has been
dealt with
scp-1548 is holding the swarm at bay
outside of the solar system at least for
the moment 05-6 returns to his office he
brings up the file on
scp-1548 he is still unsure of this
scp's true intentions it seems to be
protecting humanity but why oh 5-6 sits
back in his chair and scrolls to the end
of the file there is an update to the
file by 05-3
something that wasn't there before 05-6
opens the new entry and reads the
caption all that's left of our infinite
ever-expanding universe 05-6 scrolls
down the image is a picture taken by
serif one before contact was lost
forever it is a picture of all that
remains of the universe there are two
dots of light and nothing else but
blackness the swarm has destroyed
everything in the universe except for
those two faraway stars and our own
solar system which was protected by
scp-1548
but how long can it hold out against a
universe destroying force only time will
tell now go check out
scp-2935-o death and
scp-2000 for more tales of an
apocalyptic scale from the scp
foundation
[Music]